welcome everyone thanks for bearing with
us as we have tech issues at a tech
conference we'll be walking through
visualizing or recreating understanding
and visualizing 5:38 selections forecast
and we'll be doing so in two parts
one will be a methodology walkthrough
and interactive questions throughout and
then we'll actually dive into a Jupiter
notebook and walk through how to create
given visualizations within boquete
before all of that I'll hit you with an
agenda here we'll do introductions a bit
more fully about Matt and myself and
then actually more importantly to learn
about you we'll talk about how to
forecast and how to forecast elections
specifically one veil the secret sauce
that isn't so secret of how 538
forecasts elections and talk about best
practices of general statistical
methodologies in doing so then we'll
switch over to doing code and this is
entirely open source creating a
dashboard using bouquet and lastly we'll
discuss about simulating results and
shift over to QA so a full morning
pretty dense looking forward to what you
all think and have to say as we walk
through it so first and foremost
introductions I'm Joseph Nelson I care a
lot about giving people the skills to
use machine learning and data science
and whatever profession they work in on
Twitter I'm Joseph of Iowa happily tweet
at me or do things like that
specifically professionally I've built a
company taught classes worked at tech
companies most recently built and sold a
company called represent Li which
operate in the Civic technology space we
built a product that made it easier for
Congress to process the thousands of
inbound messages they receive every week
and sold that relatively recently I also
teach or at least have taught and
continue to consult with General
Assembly which is a 21st century
education coding school that teaches
classes in software development data
science product management UX design all
those quarter note in demand 21st
century skills I sit within the data
science vertical before that did some
work on the Facebook govern of politics
team so always been at the intersection
of tech and elections and things like
that and so was really really excited as
Matt and I put together this talk
one other thing is that I hate to say it
but this is actually the second most
important talk I'm giving this weekend
as my brother gets married this weekend
and I apparently have to do some sort of
toast so we'll see how that all shakes
out so
hello my name is Matt brems before I
move over to this slide where I
introduce myself and walk through kind
of my background one thing that I want
to call out here that I think is very
important is that Joseph with General
Assembly he taught for 2,000 hours and
you will see why this is relevant in a
moment when we move forward to my
background so what I'm particularly
passionate about is figuring out how to
put the hands of machine learning and
data science into others I'm very very
passionate about education so went to
undergrad in the middle of Indiana small
school named Franklin College most
people have not heard of it because it's
very very small I then went to Ohio
State for my master's degree in
statistics and while I was at Ohio State
that's where I fell in love with
teaching specifically I got to work with
the author of statistics for dummies I
taught with her and for her and it was
amazing to be able to work with her and
see how she communicated statistics in
particular I was somebody growing up who
didn't really understand math I didn't
understand why it was useful I didn't
understand the power behind it and I
wasn't particularly interested in it and
working with her I was able to help
inspire other people to to learn what
math can do what statistics can do and
so on while I was at Ohio State I also
did some work with Smuckers like the
jelly I interned with them and really
really importantly I fell in love with
food here I got to taste test their
products but in my spare time I built
some models and things to help predict
where people would buy certain products
what were good test markets for
different new products that they wanted
to evaluate and things like that after
wrapping up at Ohio State I moved to a
company called optimist consulting it's
a political consulting firm based here
in the DMV area and optimist consulting
or while I was there I was doing data
science to work on political campaigns
so we were using models to try and
identify who was gonna vote
what issues people cared about and what
were the people who knew who they wanted
to vote for versus the people who didn't
know who they were going to vote for and
then how could we best target the
people who didn't yet know who they plan
to support in an upcoming election it's
here where I fell in love with 538 and
in my spare time built some models and
then I moved over to general assembly a
little bit over two years ago actually
Joseph recruited me to general assembly
and that's where there's no I've ever
made
worst decision I ever made and that's
where I fell in love with that
confluence of machine learning and data
science and education so the reason that
I wanted to call it that Joseph had
taught 2,000 hours it's not a
competition but I've taught over 3500
hours with General Assembly he did not
know that I put that line in here but
that's okay cool that's kind of the
relationship that we have so happy to be
here happy to chat with you all over the
next hour and a half about 538 and
recreating visualizing in understanding
their forecasts cool so I like this joke
that those two slides probably the least
important in the presentation which is
true but it is enough for you to be like
oh maybe these guys could say something
that's helpful for us for the rest of
the day we have questions for you just
raise your hand based on the following
prompts if you will give us us to the
ability to see where the audience sits
on some of these key skills and just
sort of the proficiency in the
background so raise your hand if you
read 538 relatively regularly awesome
I'd say about 85% raise your hand if
five three it's if you've read five
thirty its electoral forecast
methodology fair number great great it's
a about 15 percent okay
raise your hand if you've used pandas
Syfy numpy okay all right maybe five
percent of use boquete most of use
pandas sci-fi don't buy good stuff and
raise your hand if you feel comfortable
with descriptive statistics that is
standard deviation summarization things
like that awesome
what about distributions and simulation
what about Bayesian statistics
inferential statistics okay I'd say
roughly about 30 to 40 percent felt good
about each of those things great
appreciate that
so today's conversation we'll walk
through each of these things in greater
depth now first and foremost I want to
discuss how to forecast and not just how
to forecast elections but more broadly
how do you go about forecasting anything
which is sort of a bold claim
we can start with talking about
elections in specificity so if you were
to forecast an election
what would you be concerned with and
actually this is an open question where
I want people to shout out answers
what would you be concerned with polling
historical results macroeconomy voter
turnout small dollar donations so
fundraising I think I heard something in
the back gerrymandering okay weather
hood the day of the polls so I turnout
factor anything else okay we gray
the--those each of those so if we were
to think about each of these factors you
said things along these lines right
horse race polls national mood
presidential sentiment turnout geography
demographics as for experts opinions
fundraising social media following and
perhaps more we even heard other things
from the audience so when it comes to
forecast and of course the first thing
is determining what could be causal and
describing the outcomes that we have one
thing that I want to unearth here and
the way that 538 goes about approaching
forecasting that should inspire you as
well is that frankly a lot of what they
do isn't the most intense or most unique
and novel cutting-edge deep neural
networks instead it's actually kind of
the opposite it's a very simplistic
straightforward subject matter informed
approach that I think is inspirational
for if you want to model any other given
outcome so if we think about modeling
broadly I think we want to zoom out and
think about much of the things that we
described that predict elections are
correct but the nuances we could create
an infinite number of explanatory
factors you know of an infinite amount
of time so the nuances of course come
with how you determine what to include
and maybe importantly what not to
include and so before we continue we'd
asked a bit of a more fundamental
question which is what is the process of
forecasting more broadly we talked about
in the context of Elections and there's
really five ish key steps first you'd
want to think about brainstorming causal
variables as we just did right the
second thing you want to be concerned
with is breaking the problem into
achievable bits
that's one thing that we're gonna walk
through today that is especially key in
the way 5:38 goes about their
methodology compared to other things
compared to other ways of modeling and
visualizing they don't just throw
everything into a model and say let's
see what sticks but instead think very
deliberately and carefully about each
the independent factors and describing
and summarizing those independent
factors then of course you need to
collect and clean that given data that
you're obtaining maybe that's poles
maybe that's fundraising whatever it is
once you have that data that's clean and
collected you want to test your results
back tests see how it performs in this
case on prior elections and more broadly
on any given situation and lastly but
perhaps most importantly frankly is this
idea that accept done is better than
perfect especially when it comes to
making any given forecast or within the
data science realm it's very common that
we as data scientists get obsessive over
thinking about every specific small
nuance i've actually adopted a
relatively new technique my own work
that i found extremely useful which is
like sprint to get to a model as soon as
possible and then go back and think
about the shortcuts you made along the
way what features did you want to clean
what other things did you want to
include omit shortcuts that you cut and
this gets to a more fundamental concept
in statistics which is our good friend
George box twentieth-century
statistician all models are wrong some
are useful and this idea is justly it's
probably as quickly as that statistician
gets of describing that done is better
than perfect don't let the perfect be
enemy the good any whatever cash a
phrase you want to use think about being
sure that you get to an achieve result
before being concerned and hung up on
the details so with that in mind let's
think about specifically the way that we
care about elections so far
we've already brainstormed our causal
variables so the second thing that we
need to do is breaking our problem into
achievable bits and from here now we're
gonna shift into 538 land and think
about how does 538 break all the factors
that you described whether that's
polling fundraising demographics turnout
in to achievable bits to model an
overall election 5:38 breaks it up into
the following categories horse race
polling fundamentals experts a noise to
explain the results of any given
election and this by the way is where we
will spend the majority of thinking
about how do you describe each of these
factors and break them
into more discreet specific bits so
again this is 538 wave describing
elections not necessarily anything novel
from Matt or myself you may have also
noticed by the way that we don't work
for 538 they don't even know we're doing
this we are just big fanboys that happen
to like go really really deep and to
what was concerned and so they decided
to give us a stage to talk about that
because you all maybe think about 5 3 8
and high regard as we do okay so with
that in mind I'm gonna say to be
continued if you will on these portions
and really zoom in on breaking the
problem into achievable bits and we'll
talk about how that's reproducible
across problem space but we're gonna
drill into how it's achieved within this
specific electoral forecasting stage so
section 2 how 538 forecasts elections
and they're not so secret sauce so first
and foremost it is top secret stuff here
is extremely closed form they haven't
posted a method all it that's absolutely
false their data is open the methodology
is open their historic results are open
and so what Matt and I have done is gone
through and picked apart and thought
about how this would describe given
electoral results and by the way if the
citation is here and deck is completely
open source on our github if you want to
be able to read and dig into this more
deeply hopefully you feel inspired and
empowered by the way that we break it
down here that you feel like oh I don't
even need to read this thing I saw what
those guys had to say if I dated DC
nonetheless let's talk about each of the
component parts okay
this formula is critical to the rest of
thinking about how results are forecast
in the context of 538 forecast is a
function of polling + fundamentals +
experts + some level of noise that's it
mostly so thinking about the way that
five-thirty a is taking this ambiguous
amorphous on onion problem space and
just said if we brought this into its
really disparate pieces we're gonna
think about horse race polls and how
those trade off we're gonna think about
fundamentals national mood perhaps
there's systemic error if everything
pulls in the same direction we're going
to think about expert opinions and
lastly we're going to think about
incorporating noise now it's important
to note that 580 has now different
levels
of their forecasts and the most recent
election you may have seen they have
light classic and deluxe and so each of
those different levels incorporate
different amounts of of these
independent factors so for example in
the light forecast the light forecast is
just based on polling and then of course
noises a part of explaining that results
in the case of the classic forecast
polling and fundamentals are taken into
account and then also noise as a result
in the deluxe version polling
fundamentals experts and noise are all
taken into account and the reason for
why there's even a distinction between
each of these levels is I think gets to
two ideas one it demonstrates the power
of one of diminishing returns of every
additional explanatory factor frankly
and two in the context of light light is
like the polls only version if you only
thought about polls and you only thought
about sampling and up waiting and down
waiting based on a pollsters reputation
and time size of sample you would get
the right forecast
clastic incorporates all 530 Yeates
mustard energy into creating their best
forecast in independence and then the
deluxe version is 538 almost cheatin a
little bit insane okay these experts
over here are also pretty good how can
we steal their results in incorporating
them into our own model right and so in
some ways the classic is almost like 530
its best foot forward and then Deluxe is
like 5 3 8 plus stealing the knowledge
of everyone else in a number of ways so
how do these perform over time generally
quite well as we know so on Election Day
the light from by the way this elections
from 1998 to 2016 the light model
performed 96.2%
accuracy the classic model in 96.7 and
the deluxe model 99 96.9 and so yes
there's hundreds of percentage points
better but it demonstrates the
diminishing returns of additional
explanatory factors now let's drill into
polling ok so while I've just been up
here saying that it's impressive that
538 takes this hairy problem breaks it
into small really simple bits
what are those simple bits drilling into
point a little bit okay and
goal here is to basically inspire you to
be like wait a second this stuff isn't
that unapproachable it just took a lot
of time it took a lot of people thinking
and applying deliver energy to a
specific problem space to achieve these
results there's not a lot of magic
things happening I'd argue zero magic
things happening so in the case of
polling we're gonna walk through two
elections in particular and apply the
methodology that 5:38 used to the
outcomes of those given elections those
two elections are the Florida Senate
which is actually to be determined it
just now was announced that well I guess
we knew this was going to happen to be
fair for a little bit but this morning
confirmed that the machine recount has
been finished and hand recount of
ballots that have been marked twice or
ambiguously or not marked at all are
going to be hand recounted by County in
Florida so we're actually talking about
an undetermined race in some ways which
is kind of interesting when Matt and I
proposed this talk we're like oh it'll
be perfect because every we'll know the
election results will be a little
criticized and be like oh this is where
they went right this is where they went
wrong we're still in it we don't even
know the result of this given election
the second election we're gonna walk
through in greater depth is Iowa 3 and
that's because it is a swingy district
that flipped seats and this flip seats
before and demonstrates a lot of the
fundamentals I'm also from Des Moines
and so that's really really key to the
understanding of why that was his choice
was selected you're welcome so in the
polling case this is a sample of the
most recent polls in the Florida Senate
okay and you'll notice there's a number
of things here we have the dates the
pollster the sample the weight that 532
signed it the result of that poll the
margin and then these adjustment things
on the side ignore those adjustment
things for a moment if you will okay I
want to drill into one specific poll if
you were trying to recreate or build
your own electoral forecast and you're
given a bunch of polls what would you
pay attention to and why so if we look
at this in the first poll we say what
are the disparate pieces of data that
are a part of this thing first you have
an animated result in keynote the result
nailed it which is the of course just
the margin between whom one in that most
or one I guess was ahead in that sample
of audience and that might be the first
thing that we pay maybe most attention
to but there's a number of reasons why
you wouldn't pay just attention to the
result right because we also care about
when was that poll taken or perhaps who
was doing it so there's other metadata
that's useful from this thing the
recency the size of the sample the
pollster the institution the point
institution themselves
okay so pause here for a second we've
just taken one single poll and we've
exposed how we can sort of double click
into the things that are more relevant
to up sample or down sample one specific
data point that's a part of the broader
picture okay now we can actually drill a
little bit deeper right we could be we
could be author in the case of 538 when
it comes to author they have gone
through and done pollster ratings which
is really going down the rabbit hole but
ultimately ultimately pollster ratings
are function of given every single time
we've seen a given institution provide
polling results on an election let's
compare those results to the elections
outcome and then based on over time we
can just compute in its most simple
fashion an average of how far that given
pollster was from the results of the
election and if you see systemic bias
for example some pollsters are
consistently perhaps plus two Democrat
or plus two Republican you can correct
for that if you see that some pollsters
seem to use junk results in some cases
for example between 2016 and 2018 538
made the decision to no longer include
people that were just casual pollsters
like mad at myself put it on a google
google link and allowing others to
answer it they no longer include that
you must be an official institution
governed by what 538 determines to be an
official institution and point is this
right here we paused here this by itself
is its own project which would be let's
just look at the outcome of polls versus
the forecast the forecasted result of
polls versus the actual electoral
results
reduce pollster ratings which then
almost rolls back into this broader drew
bigger mission statement and this right
here embodies the way that 5t 8:38
approaches forecasting problems and is a
great takeaway fryer and encourage
everyone else that is working on their
own forecasting problem in any space to
think about things break it into
discrete bits and thinking about of
those discrete bits
what could you optimize and be more
specific about in the context of polls
that is sort of the lifeblood of an
understanding of an election so it makes
sense to devote significant resources
and mindshare to thinking about how can
we improve these generally now you could
go down the rabbit hole in terms of
recent seeds you want to do like a
exponential moving average a weighted
average what's your window size or
things like this you go down the windows
are the idea of sample size and thinking
about likely voters versus all those
polled which are also weighted
accordingly but the point is we've taken
this one poll we expose that based on
this meta data there's a number of other
things that we can care and concern take
into consideration on this single poll
now soom back out to all of our polls
okay well 538 ven does is make
adjustments based on the factors that we
just described okay so there's really
three key adjustments that they care
about likely voter because polls that
include likely voters produce different
results than those that contain just
anyone's sample often they bias or I
guess it's not necessarily bias but
weight towards a more likely Republican
result in the case of likely voters they
care about timeliness in other words how
frequent the poll was selected and they
care about house effects and the way
that they combine together these
features they say they use weights based
on an algorithm and then I described
what that algorithm is and they make it
seem a little bit black boxy but I think
it'd actually be quite intuitive to walk
through what that algorithm could be so
in looking at this what you could do is
you can um be obviously fit many
different types of models or many
different types of algorithms to this
one of the simplest being a the idea of
a linear regression model or a line of
best fit just a quick show of hands how
many people are familiar with a line of
best fit or a linear regression model
okay great so given that I don't want to
spend too much time discussing that
specifically but what
5:38 is able to do is they look
historically at the gap between certain
information for example different polls
they've gotten in the past and how far
off that has been from or how much that
has influenced the real result so one
big distinction and Joseph mentioned
this earlier one big distinction in the
context of polling is polling registered
voters versus likely voters in thinking
about this when I worked for optimist
one of the things we did was do work for
the Iowa presidential caucuses and if
you think about all of the people who
are registered to vote in the state of
Iowa versus the people who actually
showed up in the caucuses to vote for an
individual party the number of people
who showed up to vote was much much
smaller than the entire registered voter
universe and so it's incumbent upon
pollsters and political organizations to
be able to take that entire universe of
registered voters every person who has
filled out their voter registration
information and converted into a likely
voter screen where they can forecast who
are the people who are likely to show up
to the election connecting this with
polling and specifically to 538 one of
the things that you can notice is that
if you were to pull all registered
voters versus just polling people who
are likely to show up these are two very
very different universes
for example 538 walks through the fact
that they're likely voter universe tends
to on average be a bit more Republican
than the entire registered voter
universe and so if there's a poll that
talks to all registered voters 538 wants
to administer some type of correction or
adjustment to that in order to take that
into account and say well we know that
based on this particular poll in this
particular region we want to shift it a
little bit more toward the right or
toward the left depending on kind of the
population of people that was sampled so
the way that they go about doing that is
they can fit a line of best fit or a
linear least-squares regression model
where one of the inputs would be what is
the result of a registered voter poll so
if I if I administered this poll to all
registered voters and I've got a huge
database of polls from maybe two
into 2016 and I say what was that gap
between or how much or I guess how
predictive was the registered voter
result of the true final result I can
get an estimate for beta one there which
connects that registered voter result to
the actual result we can also add a
correction for the amount of time to an
election or how long what was the window
of the poll itself we can also do that
for the pollster bias which Joseph
mentioned earlier if we look at the
average house effects of this individual
poll and we wanted to add an adjustment
or subtract some adjustment on the end
we can do that as well and this is all
going to be estimated likely using just
a linear regression model something that
by a show of hands about 95% of the
people in the room here we're familiar
with so it's a very very straightforward
algorithm that you can use and it's
estimated from past historical data so
538 obviously has collected a lot of
polls over a long time to be able to
generate this an estimate to a high
degree of precision what is the impact
of this pollster bias or what is the
impact of moving from a registered voter
screen into a likely voter screen and we
can also add adjustments for things like
look live calls vs. robo calls and so on
to try and get a better guess of how
predictive those are of the actual end
result that end result being the
election in November of whatever year
you're trying to forecast now a good
question would be what a point is sparse
what if you're in a place where there's
just not a lot of data on the ground to
determine that we could make these
Corrections and think about what the
margin is think about even if you have
the most accurate pollsters if there's
very sparse data points there's only so
much you can do
so contrast a highly pulled race like
the Florida Senate with even another
competitive House District where Iowa 3
where it did flip and it actually was
flipped even just four or six years ago
so it's a swingy place and got a lot of
national attention even so it only was
she or only received six meaningful and
I say meaningful because recorded by 538
of the rigorous standards they obtained
for pollsters
six meaningful poll results throughout
the summer and leading into November
right so we have very sparse amount of
data to be able to say what is the
result of this election going to look
like and not only that but if you look
at some of these results it is kind of
all over the map you have this we're
probably on plus 15.7 from September 6
to 8 and then a bunch of other
relatively lightly leaning Democratic
results right if you just took a
weighted average of the margins you get
a fundamentally different picture than
if you thought deliberately about maybe
some of the timeliness factors you're
thinking about some of the other areas
that we could consider and so the
question of what if pulling is sparse in
the answer and this is where I think
there is a fair amount of ingenuity I
mean a lot of this talk is like 5 3/8
not that great as much as we like them
this little bit that I'm about to talk
about I think is pretty novel and one
that would be useful to reproduce so
sparse point they use Cantor which is a
backronym for congressional algorithm
using neighboring topologies to optimize
regression and it's a shout out to the
cancer race where Dave brat upset cancer
and people were shocked by it because
there's very very sparse polling in a
primary in a heavily are relatively
heavily Republican district in Virginia
years ago and Cantor's premise is simple
make a guess of what polling looks like
in a given district based on similar
districts can you approximate what
polling would look like in one district
if you said this districts mood seems to
be most similar to another districts
mood that doesn't seem to be too
extraneous of a claim and so the
question becomes if that's the case how
would you go about determining district
similarity and also determining which
results you want to incorporate really
two steps an initial race guesstimate
based solely on 538 partisan lien index
in other words they think about how
partisan a given district is based on
his historical results and if you just
think about this district is generally
plus 6ar and this other district is
generally plus 6ar that's the
rudimentary guess now how do we adjust
that rudimentary baseline we compare
that district to most similar to
Drix which begs the question of
determining most similar districts and
this is the only point in five thirty
its entire methodology where they use
something beyond a weighted average
something beyond Bayesian simulation
something beyond a regression where they
use K nearest neighbors to determine the
most similar districts to one another so
adjusting to determine which district is
most similar to another district just
based on Geographic and demographic
factors so Iowa three is similar to
Michigan eight which is where nate
silver's from and from iowa so that's
kind of neat anyway so if we look at
Iowa three in this given case and we
think about more or less similar I mean
it's relatively intuitive places like
the coasts are generally less similar
and more similar Upper Midwest places
and so if we think about which districts
are most similar to Iowa and the polling
results in those districts now look at
the results that we have compared to
before where we had that one Republican
poll that was plus fifteen point seven
but if we look at the national sentiment
in comparable districts you achieve a
result that tells you a very different
story about the national mood and
sentiment of how things are trending and
this is an example of where polling sort
of bleeds into the fundamentals idea
that we're about to dip into but the
long story short of the polling section
and we'll look at the the polls again
for what they predict about our two
elections of interest
long story short of the polling section
is polling is the lifeblood of
successful electoral forecasting
devoting significant thought around the
credibility of polls the factors that
describe a polls outcome and historic
comparison of those polls is a high
value probably high also high effort
tasks so it's an area where optimizing
investing and thinking critically and
deliberately is a good return on a
modelers or forecasters time so if we
looked at the polls only forecast about
the Florida Senate race it said roughly
D plus three if we looked at the polls
only for Iowa three it's a D plus one
point six okay so that's
only now let's shift to fundamentals so
now we're shifting into the second
independent category that 5:38 cares
about in terms of determining the way
that a given district or area is going
to fall there's three different types of
Elections that 5:3 is forecasting right
senate-house governorships we've talked
mostly about House and Senate so far and
that's gonna continue to be the case but
nonetheless if we thought about the
fundamentals its many of the things that
you all shout it out at us earlier on or
at least six of you shot at us to be
fair it's not am the things that the US
House cares about or factors
fundamentals historic margin of victory
so polls whether they fall with the
trend incumbency polling generic ballots
fundraising 538 partisan lien index
where 50% is allocated to the 2016
election 25% to the 2012 presidential
election in 25 percent to the state
legislative elections congressional
approval ratings income it's candles if
relevant income at voting call record
the political experience of the
Challenger these this order is non
arbitrary this is the order that 538
states they care about in terms of the
relative weights now to be fair this is
an area where it's a little bit murky
and a little bit frankly frustrating to
reverse-engineer five three eighths
methodology as they make it relatively
opaque about how they weight each of
these factors or perhaps the methodology
of what determines a scandal versus
doesn't determine a scandal so it's hard
to say exactly what the weight of each
of these relative factors are
nonetheless the the fundamental truth of
thinking about and weighting each of
these factors matters so if we compare
the US House the US Senate it's roughly
the same thing with a few changes the
incumbent history historic margin of
victory matters and we're not gonna say
less but I'm gonna say that 538 has
better more deliberate and Kumbha seeing
adjustments or so they claim so I said
roughly that the incumbent historic
polling advantage is downsample than the
incumbency polling is is up sample
everything else relatively the same
except for political experience of the
Challenger or more the incumbent is
weighted higher in the case of the
Senate and also they add a factor
changes in state partisanship which
makes sense that the Senate we're
talking about a full state in a given
district we're talking about just
that given district so if we think about
the full state and how it's given
legislative elections within that state
or trending that gives us pretty good
insight about the mood of that given
area okay now let's compare
governorships to US House pretty similar
story to the Senate with one minor
change in commit voting call record is
not included so they're not examining
the way that the governor used to vote
or did vote on given legislation and the
other factors are included all the same
changing the state partisanship
political experience of the Challenger
all the same now thinking about what
these look like
so one gap in one admitted gap in our
understanding is understanding the
weights specifically if each of these
factors we can see the net output in
other words 538 makes it clear about how
they are up sampling or down sampling a
given race based on these factors but
the step between how they produced that
weight is not super clear nonetheless we
can get a sense of what that looks like
based on their transparent methodology
here so for example if we look at our
for example oh good case you forgot the
factors if we look at a given race the
impact score of the fundamentals is
demonstrated so in this given case the
Florida Senate race if we look to the
fundamentals you see each of the things
that are that are noted one thing that I
think is interesting to call out here is
the Challenger experience is extremely
high in the case of the Florida Senate
race you have an incumbent who's known
statewide and there's one previously
challenged by a statewide elected
officials Rick Scott used to be the
governor of Florida I guess still is and
so challenger experience is eight point
one in the Republican challengers
direction right kind of intuitive so as
stated we see the net output in terms of
the way these are shifting and affecting
the net result but we don't know exactly
the weights that allowed us
arrived at each those conclusions
presumably if we had to conjecture it is
either or both a weighted average of
historic maybe there's assigned scores
of how much incumbency matters and then
regressing those assigned scores versus
the outcome and saying okay this much of
roughly matters or it could just be a
simple weighted average doing the same
concept of looking at historically we
assigned a comment I may be a plus five
boost a plus four boost and we do a
weighted average across and say okay on
average an incumbent that's served two
terms plus four boost nonetheless that
is conjecture at best for what we know
and if we look at the net result of how
that affected the prediction for the
Florida Senate we we see that it
slightly shifts things more Democratic
overall fundamentals are far more
democratic given the national mood and
some of the other things we saw on the
slide and if we think about this in the
context of the Iowa race very similarly
we have things moving left and right one
thing that is interesting here is the
high weight of fundraising that David
Young's opponent Sidney accidie who won
the election achieved relative to to
David Young and it really shifts the
election in a blue direction and so the
net result of this race is fundamentals
plus 7.1 and we go from 1.6 all the way
up to 3.2 in terms of a democratic shift
so the long story short with
fundamentals is it is a way to
incorporate those other more-or-less
factors that feel intuitive to explain
in an elections outcome the fundraising
factors incumbency advantages things
about scandal state partisanship sort of
like the fun the well the same
fundamentals of inter scribing
fundamentals the key characteristics of
a given races attributes okay now the
last thing so remember the deluxe
forecast is 538 sort of cheating and
being like we like our forecasts a lot
but we also like these other forecasts a
lot too so how could we co-op those
other forecasts into our own to improve
its overall model and in this given case
incorporating experts is pretty
intuitive evaluate the historic
performance
wait them accordingly in shift
projections so this is just like saying
is Matt often right or is not often
wrong Matt is often wrong so I should
down wait his opinion on things that I
do in my own life right so the three
pollsters that 5:38 cares about or the
cook Political Report inside election in
sivadas crystal ball and sort of an
interesting twist here is how 538
converts their categorical descriptions
of races into numeric descriptions of
races because these three are a bit more
I don't know it's they're not as precise
as 538 in terms of providing numbers
they just provide categories of races is
it likely is it a toss-up
does it lean is it strong and based on
those 530 has gone back and identified
that the average margin of victory when
someone says lean or toss-up or so on
and so forth maps roughly to these
categories and so we've taken the
categorical input and turned it into a
numeric input this is the fancy term
feature engineering but really all it is
is thinking about if we described some
given example and compared it to
historic results what is the threshold
by which that result makes sense and so
in doing so we have the average margin
of victory based on those results we can
compare that average margin of victory
against the actual elections result and
provide a score for the pollsters and
themselves experts themselves rather and
incorporate them into our overall model
and so how does that affect our net
result well we've achieved our given
electoral outcomes now noise guys so
looking back at this previous slide here
what you'll notice is that in the light
classic and deluxe versions they care
about the polls and as Joseph mentioned
the fundamentals in the experts version
come in the classic and deluxe versions
only but one thing that's present and
all three is noise so it's important to
kind of understand this idea of noise
and how 538 takes that into account so
to throw back to George boxes quote or
we recognize that our forecasts are not
going to be perfect there's a lot of
stuff in here and there's a lot of stuff
that's very very intentional it's very
smart it's it is well vested in a lot of
subject matter expertise that people
have however we recognize that despite
all of this our models are still not
going to be perfect but they can be
useful and so we can try and improve our
models performance in the aggregate by
quantifying the noise or the uncertainty
that exists in all of the in all of the
polls and the fundamentals and just the
things that we haven't been able to
control for when trying to make these
forecasts so you can think about the
noise broken down into two different
components we've got the component on
the left side is within race error and
then the component on the right side is
between race correlation and I want to
walk through each of these so within
race error so what is the error that
specifically applies to this one race
whether it's this one congressional
district or this one Senate district or
this one or a Senate race or this one
gubernatorial race what is the error
within this race alone and the within
race error is a function of the quality
of the polls that were done so remember
earlier when we were looking at the
polls there was a weight attached to
each of those polls and higher weights
obviously meant that that poll was more
important in the final calculation so we
can use that to identify or specifically
quantify how good were our polls or how
good are our polls in this forecast the
next thing that's considered is the
number of polls there's the number of
polls as well as the diversity of those
polls or the number of different
pollsters that are used 538 has a strong
preference to use multiple pollsters
where possible because as you can
imagine if you only have one pollster
who's predicting a certain race and if
that pollster happens to be off in one
direction consistently that's gonna be
bad and so that within race error is
going to be in part a function of the
number of polls and the number of
pollsters who are contributing
information to this forecast
the last component here and I'll defer
to Joseph to define elasticity because
he really loves talking about elasticity
of districts is the elasticity of the
district or of the region that is being
considered for the election so
elasticity is the idea of how much to
concept or how much one concept responds
to some other given concept context of
prices for example when Netflix split
out their services from having the
online component and the DVD melding
component maybe you don't remember this
I do very well the price doubled and
everyone was like oh man
and they're not actually their stock
went tanking at that point because evers
like there's no way everyone's gonna pay
this amount to continue to use Netflix
wrong the price elasticity of Netflix is
relatively inelastic consumers had a
high preference to continue to pay and
use their service that is our demand in
response to the price of the good being
provided was relatively inflexible so in
the context of elections what we're
thinking about is the elasticity how
responsive a given district's mood is to
the national mood so for example if a
poll comes out that says the president
is I don't know all of a sudden in 15
points unpopular versus five points
unpopular how does that affect a given
district's mood about the overall race
in which there are going to vote and the
interesting thing here is elasticity
exists relatively independently of the
base number of voters within a given
state so for example for example states
like Delaware and Rhode Island which are
pretty consistently blue at the
statewide level have extremely elastic
voters in terms of people that are
willing to respond to national moods but
the base populations of those that are
registered or the Democratic Party are
just so much greater that the swing and
response to that national mood doesn't
matter a whole lot and so when we think
about elasticity particularly at the
presidential level we most care about is
how swingy a place is and if that place
can tip one way or another and that's
also the case for a single district or
any given Senate seat as well so for
example in the context of Virginia
Virginia is known as a state that is
relatively inelastic in terms of its
moods relative to the national president
pulling or things like this and for that
reason as a battleground state it's a
high turnout dependent state because
people are not going to be extremely
responsive to or as comparatively as
responsive to national moods
they're already have their opinion
relatively made up in comparison to
other places so to win campaigns in
Virginia turnout is generally higher
importance than it is in a place like
New Hampshire where elasticity also is
is very high relative to the given
district and so you can think about this
as a way again of almost smoothing
across our disparate data points and
different polls so similar to how Cantor
thinks about two district similarities
why don't we compare our district to the
overall national mood and think about
how that matters and how people and
voters and that district will respond
overall so those are the components that
focus on within race error and when you
think about the noise that 5:38 kind of
puts into their races or when they try
and simulate racism we'll talk about
this in a minute or they simulate
elections it's about 75% of this error
or rather I should say at least 75% of
this error or this noise comes from that
within race error however there's also a
non-trivial component called the between
race correlation so this between race
correlation recognizes the fact that
there are some trends and some things
that individual polls might miss but as
a whole we need to take into account
when we're doing forecasts so three
examples here first is a regional or
demographic correlation so perhaps polls
or perhaps fundamentals or kind of all
of the components that go into the
forecast are somehow just not there
under estimating a certain group of
individuals for whatever reason so maybe
we are under estimating the impact of
Latino voters in the upcoming election
or perhaps we are overestimating the
impact of a different group of voters
high income voters in the upcoming
election so one example of this would be
like the Rust Belt so if you think about
the 2016 presidential election it was
widely believed that Secretary Clinton
was going to pretty easily win that
presidential election however
one of the things that sort of
influenced the decision was this
regional or this demographic correlation
whereas most organizations treated each
state is independent of one another
where each race is independent of one
another
5:38 recognized that there's this
between race correlation so what that
means in the context of this example is
wild voters in each state are
independent given that after the fact
given that we knew the Trump would win
Pennsylvania
it was then likely er that Trump would
also win Michigan and Wisconsin and
states that have similar demographic
backgrounds and similar Geographic
qualities whereas what happened with
many of the other pollsters and the
other polling organizations that
forecasted a Clinton victory at 85% or
above didn't take into account this
between race correlation and instead
they said well voters in Pennsylvania
are independent of voters in Michigan
are independent of voters in Wisconsin
and so on and as we know two years after
the fact that's not the case and Nate
Silver writes extensively about this in
his 2016 post-mortem describing why 538
was closer than the other than the other
pollsters another example of between
race correlation has to do with
incumbency so for example what is the
national mood toward Congress if the
national mood toward Congress is
terrible then it's likely that this is
something that's going to ripple through
all of the elections and so if certain
elections are skewing in one direction
it's likely that other elections will
also skew in that direction one of the
very common tools that pollsters will
use is something called a generic
congressional ballot and it is something
along the lines of if the election were
held tomorrow would you vote for the
Democrat or the Republican and this
generic congressional ballot does not
put in a specific Democrats name or a
specific Republicans name but it allows
us to assess the mood overall of the
country and we can connect that directly
to how people are feeling about Congress
if we have a largely Republican Congress
and many people say they prefer the
Democrat or we notice a shift toward the
Democrat over the past six months that
is a good indicator that perhaps people
are not pleased
with Congress and the job that they're
doing so related to that this between
race correlation incumbency has in
effect specifically among incumbents if
incumbents across the board are
performing poorly then you take another
race where there's an incumbent even if
we don't have as much polling they're
probably going to perform worse as well
or if incumbents across the board
underperform their polls the same is
likely to happen to other incumbents
even if we haven't actually observed
them specifically underperforming their
polls and then finally the last example
here is a national swim so maybe there's
just this systematic polling error maybe
and sort of connecting this to the
regional demographic correlation maybe
there's a specific group that was just
under sampled for example if you think
about the 2008 election I talked earlier
about identifying a likely voter screen
likely voters versus registered voters
likely voters are often defined based on
who showed up in past elections if you
think about the 2008 presidential
election if you're gonna define your
likely voters based on the people who
showed up in 2004 and 2019 96 you're
going to dramatically underestimate the
proportion of the electorate that is
african-american because in 2008
then-senator Obama was running for
president and we noticed an enormous
surge in people of color turning out to
vote
similarly thinking about the 2016
Democratic presidential primary we see
an enormous surge in the number of young
people in the proportion of young people
getting out and voting most specifically
for senator Sanders and so based on that
we can recognize that sometimes there is
this systematic polling error when we
base things on the past it's really
difficult to forecast things in the
future when there are intangible things
that we might not be able to quantify
it's difficult to quantify the effect of
Senator Obama on people of color and the
proportion of the electorate that is
people of color based on when we haven't
had an election yet when we have no data
to support that
beyond polls and so there is often this
this example of a systematic polling
error that just affects all of the races
in the country or all races in a
particular region of the country
so 538 accounts for this noise again
there's this within race air that's
specific to that race and that makes up
at least three-quarters of the noise but
then there's also this important
component that makes up 1/4 of the noise
and that's going to be the between race
correlation so what we want to do now is
we want to move over to the code that we
have so we've got to Jupiter notebooks
you're welcome to follow along if you'd
like we'll obviously have it up on our
screen and I'll walk through the code
but if you would like to follow along
please feel free to go to this link and
I'll keep it up here for a moment
bit dot ly / PI day to DC 18 - code and
I'll give you 10 or 15 seconds to jot
that down while people are jotting that
down are there any questions that you
have before we shift over to those
notebooks give you another couple of
seconds
okay so if you go to this link what
we'll do is you'll notice that we've got
we've got this set up and there should
be two can you verify that can someone
raise your hand if you were successfully
navigated cool great awesome
so Oh HTTP okay so somebody in the
audience says that you need to go to
HTTPS please add an s after the HTTP
here Thank You Joseph did that slide
Matt didn't check it when did you finish
that slide yeah so you'll notice that
we're on Joseph's github again Joseph
of Iowa he has a tattoo of Iowa on him
it's a true he loves Iowa and everything
about it it's a little weird but so
we've got in the repo here we've got PI
day to DC 2018 we've got some we've got
to ipython notebooks that we're going to
go through so feel free to fork and
clone this down if you would like to
follow along we have Bay's walkthrough
and Senate dashboard and what I'm going
to do is I'm first going to go through
the bays walk through talking through
what is Bayesian methodology at a very
very high level we'll go through a
couple of examples we'll wrap that up
with how we turn Bayesian methods and
these the understanding of a particular
parameter of interest into election
results and then what we're going to do
is we are going to walk through how you
can set up your own Senate dashboard in
boquete and how you can export it to
HTML so that you can host it on a static
site if you would like to do so
[Music]
do not use bouquet recommend Conda
installing it
okay people in those in the top tier are
you able to see this okay thank you so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to very
quickly walk through Bayesian statistics
I know Joseph asked about this earlier
but we've had a decent number of people
join since we started so quick show of
hands how many people are comfortable
with Bayesian methods or Bayesian
statistics okay so about twenty
twenty-five percent of people come I saw
a couple of so Tso's so we're gonna
quickly recap this so the idea behind
Bayesian statistics and you'll see why
this is relevant in a minute but
Bayesian statistics is a branch of
statistics that will allow us to
directly estimate some parameter of
interest with a distribution so if you
think about a traditional statistics
class where you learn about things like
hypothesis tests and confidence
intervals the you might have heard the
term frequentist statistics that relies
on a certain interpretation of
probability and you treat those
parameters as having one value so for
example the parameter of interest we're
going to talk about is the proportion of
votes or the percentage of votes that
the Democrat is going to get I'm going
to call this P sub D or P D and if you
were to generate confidence intervals or
do a frequentist hypothesis test you
interpret P D as just some fixed value
so you might say that the Democrat will
get 53% of the vote and that's it
whereas with Bayesian statistics and
Bayesian methods instead of saying
there's this one value we can actually
put a distribution or a range of values
around it and it's different from a
confidence interval for a couple of
reasons that I'm going to gloss over in
the interest of time but what we can do
with Bayesian Messick methods is we can
actually say that 53% is our likeliest
value but we you can imagine putting a
bell curve or some really any
distribution over this that allows us to
say that the Democrat is or it's
reasonable that the Democrat wins
between 48% and 58% of the vote and then
we want to be able to translate these
distributions into electoral results we
can do throws do so through simulations
the other kind of big benefit of using
Bayesian inference or Bayesian methods
is that we're able to combine two things
together we can combine our data and the
term we're gonna use for this is our
likelihood with our prior beliefs when
you're doing frequentist statistics or
the classical statistics that you might
have learned in undergrad or in high
school if you took like AP SATs if you
go ahead and do frequent to statistics
the the only thing that you have is the
data you let the data speak for itself
but the way that science and knowledge
work is that we can we recognize that
there are certain values that something
might take on for example depending on
the Senate race you're talking about oh
the congressional race you're talking
about maybe we know that it is all but
impossible for a certain person to
receive eighty percent or ninety percent
or a hundred percent of the vote so
instead we want to say our prior beliefs
fit this certain kind of model and so
Bayesian inference is going to allow us
to summarize our prior beliefs and our
data and combine them together so that
we can get hopefully a more informed and
a better result so four terms that I'm
going to use here distribution I've
already described this a little bit but
a distribution is the set of all
possible values of a variable and how
frequently we observe each of those
values so in the context of PD again PD
is the percent of votes that the
Democrat is going to get in the upcoming
election so the distribution for PD will
be the set of all possible percentages
of votes that the Democrat can get and
how frequently we would see each of them
you can visualize that intuitively like
a histogram or a bar chart our prior
distribution is the distribution that
you and I come up with that say what are
our prior beliefs or what is our prior
understanding about PD that percent of
votes that the Democrat is going to get
our likelihood is how the data
summarized that parameter of interest
it's how the data summarized PD and then
the posterior distribution is going to
rely on some math that's going
to take the prior beliefs that we have
and our data and combine them together
so intuitively I like to think about the
posterior distribution as a compromise
between that prior distribution and the
likelihood that we generate and so what
I've done is I've explained these terms
but I want to put some code to this and
actually show what this means so go
ahead and import these packages and
you'll be able to run the entire
notebook if you'd like but in putting
this into action I want to be able to
generate some data through numpy I want
to be able to plot and visualize this
together so let's say that I live in a
district where I really really strongly
believe that the Democrat is going to
lose badly so then what I want to do is
without seeing any data or without
taking any polls I want a prior
distribution that matches those beliefs
it's common for us to use a beta
distribution when we model probabilities
the beta distribution is a distribution
that is continuous between 0 and 1 and
that's it
so if you're talking about probabilities
which you can take on any number in
between 0 and 1 this is a common thing
for us to do so there are two numbers
that we have to specify if we want to
use that distribution they are called
in this case they are called a and B so
I've already filled in this code for you
but if I think the Democrat is going to
lose badly I set a to be 10 and B to
equal 40 I'm glossing over the details
of how I picked those but if you run
this cell you can see this distribution
so on the horizontal axis these are all
of the possible values of PD that the
proportion of votes that the Democrat is
going to get on the vertical axis we
have the density so we have kind of the
probability or the likelihood of each
individual value which gets a little
weird to talk about for continuous
distributions but in this case I picked
my values here it's alpha and beta but I
picked these hyper parameters
specifically because I think the
Democrat is going to do really badly so
if we look at this almost all of my the
weight in my distribution based on my
previous beliefs about how the Democrat
is going to do is between about
10% and 30 or 35% so this is an example
of coming up with a prior distribution
for our parameter in many cases this
involves subject matter expertise in and
understanding of these probability
distributions to show a different
example let's say that I think the
Democrat will win but I'm not very
certain about that so visually before we
even run this if you think about how I
can shift this blue distribution here if
I think the Democrats going to win but
I'm not as certain you can imagine
taking this distribution pushing it over
to the right hand side where the
proportion of votes the Democrat gets is
probably going to be greater than 50%
but not all of the weight of that
distribution will be beyond that so I
pick alpha and beta to be 7 and 5 and we
get this distribution so the likeliest
value for pd is around 60% it's actually
at exactly 7 divided by 12 but we see a
much broader spread because we're less
certain about what's going to happen the
last example let's say that I just moved
to a district and I've literally know
nothing about either candidate in this
case I want a prior distribution that
were that reflects that idea I'm not
gonna put my finger on the scale I'm not
going to discuss or try and influence
things in any way and I want a prior
distribution that that reflects those
beliefs I set my alpha and beta
parameters to be equal to 1 and so then
my distribution is this very boring flat
line in between 0 & 1 so we can come up
with a range of prior beliefs that goes
from completely uninformative to
something that is much more specific if
we have informed previous beliefs so
that's our prior now how do I connect
this with my data in this case I'm going
to talk about data in terms of polling
so remember that our posterior
distribution is a combination of our
prior and our data so we have to figure
out how does that data or how does that
likelihood come into
the likelihood function should be a
reasonable model for how that data is
generated so if I administer a survey to
n different people and I say do you plan
to support the Democratic candidate in
the upcoming election a reasonable model
counting up how many people say yes is
the binomial distribution what we're
doing here is you can think of these as
n fixed
trials with a certain probability of
success there are only two outcomes
success and failure in this case I'll
say success is voting for the Democrat
failure is not voting for the Democrat
and oh and I just mean that in terms of
like actual statistical terminology not
no personal opinions here although we
really so non-political until now Matt
sorry well they saw my Twitter handle so
if you go to my it's been political
recently but so we've got n fixed trials
we have two possible outcomes the
Democrat or not the Democrat and we can
treat these trials as independent or if
I assume that I sampled these
individuals from a random sample or a
true random sample then I can assume
that these observations are independent
of one another which matches all the
assumptions you would need for the
binomial distribution it's just a
convenient way for us to count up how
many successes we observed out of a
fixed number of independent trials hey
Matt what's a binomial distribution what
what's a binomial I'm asking you to
review the name of the distribution oh
so a binomial distribution is going to
be a distribution that can model exactly
that so specifically here what I want to
say is let's say that I were to survey
40 different people and 30 of them say
they plan to support the Democrat the
binomial distribution is a very very
convenient distribution to say how
likely is it out of 40 people that I get
one person to support the Democrat or
two people or three people or four
people and so on so this binomial
distribution is going to be a good way
to model exactly that Thanks so let's
say that I get or I administer a survey
and I get responses from 40 people
thirty of them say that they plan to
support the Democrat if you run this
cell this is what that binomial
likelihood will look like this is saying
how likely is it that my probability of
success or the proportion of people who
vote for my Democrats are each of these
values given the data that I observed so
here if I observed 30 people who said
they're gonna vote for the Democrat out
of 40 total individuals it makes sense
that the peak of this distribution 30
over 40 is right around 75 percent in
fact it's exactly 75 percent and so this
is the binomial likelihood based on the
binomial distribution which models how
likely is it that we observe different
probabilities of success given the data
that we observed from our survey one
note that I want to make is the
likelihood here is not dependent on our
prior these are totally independent of
one another I came up with my prior
distribution or my prior beliefs before
looking at any data or before
administering a survey now my likelihood
is where my survey data comes in or my
polls come into play so let's say that
instead of doing a survey of 40 people
and getting 30 responses in support of
the Democrat I sample 400 people and I
get 300 people who say they'll support
the Democrat well we still expect there
to be a peak right around 75% because
we've got 300 successes out of 400
trials
3 over 4 is 75% but we're much more
certain that that distribution is going
to be very very close to 75% because my
sample size is larger this seems to make
sense if you have a sample size of 10
versus a sample size of a million and
you get 8 out of 10 or 800,000 out of a
million people who support somebody
there's way more certainty in this
800,000 out of a million people to take
this to logical extremes so in this case
as that sample size increases the
certainty of that likelihood becomes
more certain or that distribution
becomes narrower so to look at a prior
and a
likelihood together let's say that I
used this situation where I think the
Democrat will win but I'm not very
certain
so my prior distribution I'm gonna pick
a beta 7-5 and suppose I administer a
survey to four hundred people and three
hundred of them support the Democrat in
this case I'll use my binomial four
hundred trials with three hundred
successes as that likelihood and this
visually is what we get
so in orange the big nice-looking bell
curve that is our prior distribution and
our prior distribution is centered at
about 58 or 59 percent exactly seven
divided by twelve but there's a lot of
spread under that prior distribution for
the likelihood distribution you'll
notice that the Green Line representing
the mean of that distribution is at
seventy-five percent because again we
saw that 75 percent of our people said
yes they'll support the Democrat in that
poll now the reason that the Green the
likelihood looks smaller is that the
likelihood here is and I'm gonna gloss
over this technically not a distribution
so it's not going to integrate to one or
the area under the curve isn't going to
add up to a hundred percent and so
because of that that's why the
distribution looks a lot smaller it's
not going to affect any of the work
we're doing but just something to keep
in mind so the important points here are
to look at those vertical lines so the
orange line represents the mean of our
prior beliefs the Green Line represents
the mean of our likelihood or the
likeliest likelihood value so based on
this if you think about what is going to
happen to our posterior mean or when we
combine our prior beliefs and our data
together that posterior mean is should
fall somewhere in the middle of the
orange and the green lines and that's
because the posterior distribution is a
compromise between our data and our
prior beliefs so I've written a function
here that will allow us to plot the
distributions together and we can just
pass in
what do we think our beta distribution
parameters will be and then what do we
think our our binomial likelihood
parameters are going to be so let's say
that again I think the Democrats gonna
win but I'm not very certain about that
and I survey 40 people and I get thirty
positive responses from that if I model
these I'm looking at my prior and my
likelihood which give me that posterior
distribution and in this case that
posterior distribution looks like it's a
compromise or somewhat in between my
likelihood and my prior but in this case
the mean is closer to my likelihood
which means my likelihood is providing
stronger evidence here because remember
my prior believes that wasn't very
certain about it so the posterior more
closely matches that likelihood
similarly we can run an example here
where I thought the Democrat was gonna
perform really really badly but we run a
poll and the Democrat gets fifty five
percent support out of a hundred people
and we can visualize these distributions
as well so again the important thing is
to look at the means of those
distributions and in this case we also
see that the blue posterior mean is this
compromise between our prior beliefs and
the survey data or the actual data we
have observed putting this all together
this is under the hood what 538 does and
what they do is they use this to turn
into or turn this into election
predictions so let's say that I have
that posterior distribution and I pull
one value from the posterior
distribution remember my posterior
distribution tells me what is the
probability of support or sort what is
the percentage of votes the Democrats
going to get well if I pull one value
from that posterior distribution and the
Democrat gets more than fifty percent of
the votes
just assuming that there's two people in
the race and getting fifty percent means
you win I'm gonna call that a win for
the Democrat if I do this for a hundred
thousand different elections or get a
hundred thousand
different values from the posterior
distribution I can then in effect
simulate a hundred thousand theoretical
elections if I simulated a hundred
thousand elections and the Democrat
ended up winning about sixty thousand of
those hundred thousand I'm going to
estimate that the Democrat has a 60%
chance of winning the upcoming election
so we can run this here in a in a quick
example if I have a beta 7-5 that's
where I think the Democrat is going to
win but I'm not certain and I pull 40
people and thirty people say they're
gonna support the Democrat I can
generate a hundred thousand observations
from the posterior distribution here I'm
calling that PD if I plot this histogram
here this describes my posterior
distribution of PD or PD is the percent
of votes I think the Democrat is going
to get so out of a hundred thousand
trials we can see that on average the
Democrat seems to get about seventy
percent of the votes and in almost all
of the cases the Democrat is getting
more than 50% of the votes here I can
then convert this into elections by
literally going through every value in
the simulated distribution and say well
let's call this a win if they had higher
than 50% and we can check out that mean
we look here based on that data we
sampled the Democrat has a ninety nine
point nine to five percent chance of
winning
based on that posterior distribution
which combined our poll and our prior
beliefs so specifically what 538 is
going to do is they're gonna use a more
sophisticated method of combining all of
their polls together and bringing in
more noise but they're going to get a
distribution of values this posterior
distribution of values for each of their
races then they can simulate one race
across each of the possible Senate races
and say huh the Democrats won 26 seats
in this out of the 35 that were
in this election and then we can do the
same thing again over and over and over
and over again to get a better
understanding of how this is going to go
for and get a probability estimate for
how likely is it that an individual
senator wins their seat or an individual
governor wins their seat or an
individual party wins control of the
House of Representatives or the Senate
so all put together in one cell you can
see this in a different example where in
this case it's far less likely that the
Democrat is going to win and we estimate
that at about 5% the last thing I want
to do is let's shift over to the other
notebook and look at the let's look at
how we can take this and build it out in
boquete together and what a dashboard
looks like so I'm going to open up the
Senate dashboard ipython notebook or
jupiter notebook i should say up here we
have a lot of imports we're going to
grab we're going to generate a map we're
going to generate a histogram and we're
going to generate options for this so
that if we wanted to look at the light
versus classic versus deluxe we could do
that the function that we've got here is
going to set up a radio button to say do
we want the light do we want the classic
do we want the deluxe forecast so
acknowledging this upfront this button
is there for show and will not actually
change results however we can then set
up our map for for our forecast and we
can use bouquet to do this so bouquet
has a built-in set of values for all of
the states we can unpack all of the
states and one of the nice features of
bouquet as a package is it will generate
interactive visualizations so we can
determine certain tools that we want to
exist here and we're going to see these
in a moment so I'll just run this
function to run the cell to create map
results
I'm going to just simulate how many
Senate seats are won by the Democrats
I'm just pulling this from a
distribution rather than bringing in a
bunch of 538 data which will take more
than the five minutes that we have left
and similarly I've set up a histogram
here where this histogram is also going
to be interactive you'll notice that
there's tools in here as well you'll see
something called a tooltip we'll be able
to visualize this in a moment and then
this is where all of those pieces will
be pulled together so if you want to
generate a bouquet dashboard this is how
you would do it you can define a
function for each of the things that you
would like to do and then they have a
function called grid plot that will
allow you to organize all of these
together so in my top row I'm just gonna
have the options or the buttons for the
light classic and deluxe forecast and
then in the row beneath that I'm going
to have my histogram on one side and my
histogram is going to show the
simulations that I just generated and
then on the right hand side I'm gonna
have the map of the United States
bringing in the state's data that
bouquet has loaded up and if I want to
generate this dashboard and open it in a
notebook I run these two functions
output notebook is going to
unsurprisingly output this data in the
notebook and then show is actually going
to pull it up so what we see here is
again there's those radio buttons up top
for light classic and deluxe we have and
I'll zoom out a little bit forecasting
the race for Senate so on the left hand
side we have the number of Democratic
Senate seats and we can move over to a
map of the United States and as you
mouse over there are Alderman so that we
can see this there is this thing called
a tooltip that we've defined to be able
to report as you mouse over a bar what
is the number of Democratic seats that
some
so here we've got 45 seats 46 seats 47
seats you'll notice that once the
Democrats control the majority of the
seats that turns the bars turn to blue
and then over here we have a map of the
United States which similarly is is
interactive so you'll be able to zoom in
here but we can look at Iowa or we can
look at Kansas or we can look at Indiana
and the tooltip here shows what is the
name of that state as well as the
probability of a Democratic win in that
state to be clear these are arbitrary
values for this yes these are arbitrary
values in here although better than some
of the things we saw the first time that
I showed this to Joseph he's like he's
like why's Texas so blue it's only light
blue here but so what you might want to
do though is say you know Jupiter
notebooks are nice they're helpful tools
but beyond this what we want to do is we
actually want to take these tools we
want to deploy them somewhere well
boquete has a convenient way for you to
do that as well
you can generate an HTML file so using
the output file you can just send this
to an output add an HTML suffix to it so
that it will automatically render in a
in a browser window for you so that you
can look at this outside your Jupiter
notebook additionally if you one of the
other things with this is I'm going to
click back to the Jupiter notebook for a
moment as you generate this output file
if you look back in your folder there is
now a folder called output HTML there so
you can take that dashboard save it as
an HTML file and then once you've saved
that as an HTML file you can attach that
or load that onto any static site of
your choosing so that you can have this
interactive dashboard available on a
personal website not limited to 538
forecasts but this is a convenient way
to leverage that bouquet library to do
something interactive it's built on top
of JavaScript it is a flexible library
for visualizations of the interactive
type so with that yeah so we are running
shine time so a few things one is that
matter I have to happy to hang out for
questions because we're Avenue to the
Q&A time at this exact time
second thing is high-level notes to
comment and leave you with some parting
thoughts first thing is the importance
of breaking seemingly big hairy problems
and discrete smaller ones and focusing
your time where there's gonna be the
biggest value in terms of in this given
case your forecasts output inaccuracy
the second thing and something that I
want to chime in on our Bayesian
statistics discussion is sort of like a
little anecdotal note and then hopefully
something inspirational if you've never
used Bayesian stats before is this idea
that when I first encountered Bayesian
statistics I remember someone telling me
that they are able to summarize the
world with like a single data point and
I was like that's that's not true you
don't know what the world looks like
with a single data point you need at
least two for an average or something
right and Bayesian statistics introduces
this world where you can think about as
Matt described identifying a prior and
then seeing how that prior would change
relative to a single piece of evidence
to produce some posterior distribution
and that way of thinking in terms of
distributions and in probabilistic
instead of single point estimates is
incredibly powerful as you can see for
what it unlocks for us the last thing is
that this code is entirely open source
including both the the Bayesian walk
through the deck and the bouquet
dashboard the bouquet dashboard is
purely exemplary as Matt described and
something that you should use as a
reference as you continue to think about
building things like this so hopefully
you've taken away an ability at least at
a minimum and appreciation of breaking
down methodologies and a maximum of a
strong understanding of Bayesian
statistics how 5:38 thinks about things
and a little bit about more about
bouquet so with that in mind I want to
thank you all for coming out at 9:00
a.m. on a Friday and listening Matt and
I talked about stats for way too long
and welcome you if there's questions to
come hang out and chime and throw
tomatoes and that type of thing so
thanks so much
[Applause]
what do us to do now
Oh for QA sure all right well we need
the Q's we'll try with the a hi this was
really great I just wondered if you
could maybe contrast making dashboards
in bouquet with maybe other tools like
I'm just gonna provide a quick so we
only described bouquet in a single
example which is one tiny piece that
well interactive visualization of course
within Python land there's hollow views
there's as you described plotly I like
using folium for maps there's a high
array of different libraries that you
could choose and use within Python
specifically why bouquet motley etc are
quite strong you know where we have to
know JavaScript to make interactive
things which is really quite neat for us
folks that are not great at JavaScript
broadly speaking though in terms of
making dashboards I don't think it's you
should limit yourself to thinking too
frankly need to have Python of course
there's like great tools like tableau
where it's just a greater lot of success
accessibility based on someone's
background but broadly speed
Bokke is a great tool to marry if you
wanted to do some level of modeling and
forecasting within Python all the data
is already in Python so why not export
it and make it easy for your team's to
be able to view it in Python as well you
specifically talked about I think it was
like in the noise model like changes in
demographic turnouts and stuff like that
and then I think it was in the another
factor like scandals and stuff like that
as someone who followed 5:38
presidential forecasts related to Donald
Trump and I think you mentioned this
that like Washington Post or some other
people were like 0% chance of winning
like I was following it up right up
until election saw it jump to like 33
percent was like what's going on there
was the James Comey scandal like various
things like that where's that reflected
in polling data or was that like other
like the other features that you
mentioned in their poll like scandals
like them sensing some kind of different
demographic turnout etc yes so so I
think that's a really good point to
bring up and that is while we treat each
of these features is independent of one
another while we look at polling
independent of the fundamentals
independent of and so on one of the
things that I think is important is that
information is going to come in in a lot
of different avenues here so as an
example it is possible that what they
did was you know at five thirty it was
maybe they added a scandal component to
Secretary Clinton I would imagine given
emails in Benghazi and like just the
news following all of that but there was
already some component of that there
that being said they might have tweaked
that to make that larger that's
something that was additionally
represented in polls and so if you look
at polls before it was like eleven days
before or whatever she was doing
substantially better after that point
there was a dramatic drop related to
that that's something that you see all
throughout the 538 forecast for example
one of the components that Joseph talked
about was the experts they literally
take a an average of the expert
weights or the experts ratings and
combine those together and they feel
that or Nate's over wrote in his
methodology article that what the
experts do is really good at picking up
on these micro level trends that other
people haven't yet picked up on and so
it's a leading indicator in that sense
however it is also often a lagging
indicator of other things and so for
example if there's the Congressional
ballot that starts heading in a certain
direction
or if there's if there is economic
evidence to support a certain candidate
or something like that what will
ultimately end up happening is that the
538 notice that the experts ratings will
not just be independent of that and just
focus on those micro level things but
will also be influenced by other things
that they're already bringing into their
model all this is to say is that a lot
of this is going to be very complex in
these there's going to be an individual
piece of data that might influence
things in multiple situations whether
it's in changing demographic trends
whether it's in scandals whether it's in
experts ratings or so on
we knew the question of 2016 would come
up and that could be its own 90-minute
thing in terms of what 538 messed up I'd
condensed it to like really three key
things the first is that the polls are
relatively well done actually in terms
of predicting the way that individual
places would vote it was simply the
incorporation of who was pulled properly
in terms of a number of swing states the
second is as matt described systemic
factors in terms of when given for
example if you knew pennsylvania would
go one way that would say things about
Ohio and Michigan as well and the third
thing is that 538 called out the fact of
sparse polling in areas where they wish
they had more Michigan is a good example
of that so if you had to condense it
down to three things it's pulling the
right audiences systemic air across
polls and the need to have richer data
across all regions also Russia for a
presentation I could follow this and
adapt it but if you were I would imagine
there this is all in a pipeline going
all day 365 and would you change any
choices and things such as Bayesian
versus some more classical techniques
other other approaches for performance
for the fact that you might be doing
earlier discussion kay his neighbor
would can you just do that once and then
incrementally change things or do you
have to start over every iteration so
the question is about we described a
number of smaller bits that went into
the overall methodology yes the question
is if you edited any of those individual
bits how that affect the other
components and over time if you're gonna
do this on massive scale yeah repeatedly
which you would that change your choices
at all and in some of the statistical
approaches you've used yeah so I think I
think you're bringing up a really
actually good question that faces a lot
of statistical modeling so I can take it
out of the context of Elections for a
second then bring it back in so for
example asset managers have this problem
where they do a really good job of
identifying least the top ones assets
that are correlated and creating
portfolios that de-risk and assume some
amount of risk and let's say they take a
bunch of new funds and new investment
they want to manage an additional number
of people's money they can't simply just
buy an additional amount of assets of
the existing strategy that they want to
use because there's a limit amount of
liquidity things are correlated in
different ways you can't just take this
and multiply it by ten so the question
of if you have a strategy that you
relatively like builds up of individual
component parts how do you adjust and
scale that strategy is not unique to
just elections in the context of
elections there's I think I would I
would describe two things that I'd be
really cognizant of in this context
there's a lot of systemic error that
could cause one given technique to
affect every other technique across the
board so for example Cantor is an
example where it's intra is in contrast
to many of the cross-race polling
factors that Matt described in noise
Cantor is actually the antithesis of
that it's like why don't we try to make
two districts that are different looks
similar to one another and actually
correlate them whereas at the same time
de-risking some amount of the noise says
let's not assume that places could not
have systemic error across them and so
in other words if you changed a factor
that affects multiple parts of your
overall forecasts I think that's an area
where you're going to be performing near
heart surgery in terms of editing a
component there's other factors however
I don't think that's the case
pollster ratings is a good example of
something that you could do in
Independence and siphon off of the other
parts of the aggregation and forecasting
that you're doing ultimately
and then the second part of your
question was around how often do you
like rerun and retune and retrain and do
you do it entirely which i think is
extremely like most things context
specific in the context of 5:38 in
pollster ratings I actually don't know
how often they redo it but that's not
relevant to the point of my answer which
is that you don't need to redo the
pollster rating every single time a poll
comes out if I had to estimate I would
estimate that 538 redoes their pollster
ratings after each election at most
right and then reruns that model and
says these are the new scores for which
we believe a given pollster is going to
output so the timeliness of updating a
given models output is dependent upon
how just in time the results need to be
and you describe kN I would presume
without knowing of course actually that
they ran the Cana and model once to say
these graphic demographics are
demographically similar we're assuming
these geographies are demographically
similar that's enough and sufficient to
use this for 2018 going forward maybe
they will rerun that for 2020 but long
story short how often you update a given
component of your model is extremely
dependent upon what the purpose of that
thing is like contrast that with Netflix
real quick the recommendation algorithm
updates all the time and in fact is at
least multiple times per day across user
actions because they have so many and
that dictates how many people are going
to spend time on site and things like
that which updating the recommendation
algorithm needs to happen much more
frequently compared to updating the say
KN for which states are most similar in
the context in 538 and really quickly
just so as I mentioned at the beginning
my background prior to General Assembly
is working in in politics and political
consulting and so one of the things that
we did was we had set up a series of
tools that would allow us to much more
efficiently do our work for example we
weren't doing the same stuff that
five-thirty it was doing but
understandably nate silver is not
actually sitting at a white board and
redoing this every day and updating
their predictions and there's tools and
pipelines that exist for that the reason
that I bring that up is that we did
something similar in the context of
actually trying to model with our data
in this very efficient way because we
knew what the data was going to look
like we knew what the output was
supposed to look like and so on and with
that we
we would update it after every election
cycle and there are two main reasons for
that the first reason is that you only
get approximately aside from early
voting and absentee ballots and all that
one day of voting or one day of data so
you've got Election Day but that's
really it so in terms of you know if you
think about classical machine learning
where you do training and testing sets
and you evaluate your model on your
testing set it's really hard to evaluate
your model on and your processes more
broadly on unseen data just because well
until November 6th or November 8th or
whatever happens you don't have that
actual data so that's one thing the
other thing is that as you try and make
major changes during the election not
there aren't just the inevitable bugs
that will come into play and you don't
want anything to be down but the other
thing is you then run the risk of
putting your finger on the scale too
much because you say I mean for example
let's say that 538 after Comey made his
announcement said wait Clinton's too
high
we need to relook at this and so they
start tweaking things in order to get
the result that they expected to get
rather than saying let's trust the
process let's let our model and this
infrastructure we've built up kind of
suss that out and let's let the public
determine that rather than us so I would
agree with Joseph that they probably are
doing major updates and tunes to these
after every major election thanks for
the presentation I you actually bring up
the question I want to ask it's about
the model evaluation I believe that you
have a handful of models in hand but you
just show a chart about you're in Sampo
evaluation but that is exempt oh it's
like the noise which will make up about
94 percent that would bring up the
concert of overfitting so I mean like in
economic forecasting where consumers
like me for forecasting square error or
like the other evaluation and stuff but
you didn't show in the presentation I'm
just curious about how its user the
final model yeah so in the context of
trying to forecast when you don't
actually have that that real data you
don't have
Valon like data on which to evaluate you
have to do what we do all too frequently
in data science and you've got to make
assumptions and you've got to just use
the data that you have so that data that
you have can come in many different
forms if you're thinking about the day
or the week before the election you can
often get early voting and absentee
ballot numbers which those are updated
like daily by individual secretaries of
state across the United States and you
can use that information to try and
identify within a week of the election
or within a month of the election how
your stuff is tracking relative to what
you expect that being said more broadly
you're absolutely right there's this
enormous concern how can I forecast what
the election is going to look like in
2016 when we don't have that information
so you rely on absentee ballots and
early voting you can rely on primary
elections if you have that but to be
perfectly honest you just try and set up
proxy variables and hope they're good
enough you might say I'm gonna define a
like election so a an election that's
like 2016 is probably 2012 and or 2008
and so maybe you use both of them
together or each of them independently
as like as a stand-in for your Y
variable or as the 2016 presidential
election but even with that there's no
there's not a good answer to that
because optimally we want that data but
we just don't have it so we have to
essentially create data or use data that
exists as bad though it may be I think
one thing to note is that's actually one
of the key value-adds of Bayesian
modeling is you can compare the limited
amount of evidence that you have
compared to what your beliefs about a
given system may be so in the context of
538 they actually have a Bayesian model
that estimates how election day is going
to look based on national mood and based
on comparable elections so 2014 for 2018
because it's midterm years and as we
approach election day the weight that
that Bayesian prior receives relative to
the polls and the recency of those polls
decreases until it's actually zero on
the day of the election so in other
words
only are they saying that we have this
prior of what we believe the mood looks
like and now we get this new poll let's
see it now with a slightly lower
posterior and look look look look that
prior weight decreases in importance as
we get closer to the date of the event
and so yeah the only thing that I wanted
to add is the key value of Bayesian
statistics largely is dealing with
sparse amounts of information I just
like thinking about there are other
institutions also do the forecasting and
like how would you know the five that
538 their model or their rapport cousin
Teresa will be better than other
institutions yeah how do we know that
theirs is gonna be better than other
institutions yeah we looked at other
institutions and cared they are the
elections know the with the main reason
that we focus on 538 here is a few
things one is their popularity frankly
among the data science community and
understanding agreed agreed
recognition of their significance and
the second is they're so open up their
methodology and their data that it's
easy to give a presentation walking
through how they go about things in
terms of like why we think 538
objectively is valid independent of
cherry-picking nice things that it makes
it easy to give a conference talk about
their objectively quite good because the
amount of rigor in to Matt's point
earlier about trusting the process as
much as that is a cliche about we
believe so for example silver is very
open and we'll tweet throughout these
electoral process about how much he
thinks a new factor could it could not
matter and so roughly in March of last
year he was thinking about incorporating
that local state legislature element of
like how much does the state mood in the
Statehouse affect national elections
House elections governorships things
like this and he tweets out this massive
Twitter thread what he's like
based on all my estimation and work here
this did matter quite a bit in Prior
elections and then he baked that into
the 2018 model with that knowledge at
that point in time and so one reason
that 538 is so strong that they lean so
heavily into rigor and empiricism over
perhaps saying we want to see a given
result and we want to backstop our
performance against that results so much
so that even I think pollsters engage in
hurting where if they see that they're
an outlier
they think that their result is wrong
and they'll put their own finger on the
scale to bring their result closer to
what others in the district may see so
long story short by y53 for this
presentation openness of data
recognition of understanding reliance on
empiricism and also they used some micro
level data with that they also use some
micro level data
yes yeah across all levels right
national mood individual district states
it's great thank you yes so though
they're gonna kick us out but thank you
all again very much for your time and
your attention
[Applause]